マックナゲットって何キロカロリーでしょうか元10パックナゲット南輝小ビン
全然しらねどこで280kcal 名乗って280かける20は後1600kcal 今
こちらに5600系のハードリードバックナゲットがあるんですけども俺は東京で何を
身に付けたか
そう大群の群れに流されない力
それだけだというわけで早速今日はマックナゲット100って言っていこうと思います
おい
以前のリボっちがー
家族亭
入来な最近マジであのフードファイターの際のあるんじゃねーかって感じになってるん
だよここで見せてできればいいなと思っておりますいただきます
[音楽]
本論じゃあ夜は馬や生むんですよ
まあを美味しくいただいてるうちに一つだけと豆知識していたお願いしますなんか
私もとまっくっ
[音楽]
まずは10個度もあった
まず前が折れたんですよ
[音楽]
20超えた男だったら余裕ですよここからが大人
なるほどずっと綺麗でいくつですかも bd 4階
女塾を食べました
なるほどね大いう感じかうーん
そう来るのねー
なーるほど6月武家ばやばいぜこれ
[音楽]
ん
どっか行った体を止めてくれって叫んでるかはが止めてくれて叫びたかっているんだ
馬場とほんとまあマックナゲット上からてるか上から出るからですよまず食べる食べて
いくんですけどあくまでたどり着けるナムになてっと
女せてるんですよさあこれ抱っこ今
26とかですよね赤ちゃんっ
やっぱりで協力して取れる100波カメラ部でよかったら201本よね
寝てっていきますよ
こんだけ行っててくれないわけないのでヨンギダウンねん
見えません
me
うんうんっ
[音楽]
民主党ですよそもそも30
3ぬ
いや本店は gonzo
[音楽]
ています
俺出すそのままで沿っナゲッツを横になっちゃうってなった
[音楽]
ています
しています
[音楽]
泣かないで
ねえ誰てる垂れてるあすごい
勝ち抜けしてるじゃん
スイーツ
ぬるー
[音楽]
ああああああん
はい桜がなのでだけど今算数1個30個になっております
姉だけ自信満々だっているんですが完熟を食べて脳ですか
まいっちゃ会でも俺見たんだよいろんなユーチューバーの方が100ことを食べてるん
ですけどみんなね3人とか4人とかこうなんかこそでやってるんですよ
天へよ
俺2人でやり呼びなかなかさん4人くらいでナゲットキャップ腫れてるねふたりで
頑張ろうと違いここだけ食べればいいからがんばってがー
あっし
なにいっ
[音楽]
もう普通に限界
たぶん30が限界ですね
まずマックなると私好きじゃね
ソースなんかじゃあお付き合いたこれ1人に1個ずつお風呂あるみたいな感じがそう
いう
それが一番大変なことになる試みている頃あの2つの世界を一致する特許を超え
つなげるですまあほぼ野望
赤ちゃんなもっと映画な月だムービーと口を超えるな月親子
マイ理研にはナゲットが付いてくるえっ
うんうん
ラップだってるッ
うっ
あの
ナゲット号いいぞはっはっは
[音楽]
[笑い]
山向けていくつ食べれ校
[音楽]
[拍手]
やっぱじゃっアマ相撲
imo 6です
ブーツほんとこれ ran
[音楽]
すっ
ee 4 a
[音楽]
あっはカフェ案にねやっぱジャン手ぶら砂やたっちゃうっじゃっ犬っぽい
いや猪木出そうと思ったんねぇうん
さあラストにことになりましたじゃんけんぽん
ちょっとなってくれあー天パ強くだけ
ん
それ以上言っジャッジパンッ
ame
ん
true
冗談抜きでいい
本舗なかったで多分普通の人は
2人でご全部食べることは相当困難と同ボードでぜひ寿司になるかと試してみて
ください
知らないことあってしないでくださいばいばーい
[音楽]
[拍手]
me